uh stories about your other son stories
about my other son well guess who she
doesn't like
[Applause]
uh so he
got like suspended for school from
school you're going to love the
rest he was like
seven
I I I go to pick him up and I go into
the principal's office like what's the
deal and she was like it's pretty
serious and I was like what
happened and um she was he was caught
kissing a girl behind the
dumpster and I was
like okay what else she was like that's
it I
go why is he suspended she goes it's
how it's how he got her there and I was
like pause I did the same thing I did
the same thing and I was like I go how
did you get
her he said she said he just walked up
they were
set and he said to her
hey go get behind the
dumpster
and I go and then what and she was like
and then they went behind the dumpster
I'm
like I why why why is he what why is he
in trouble he's not the [__] who went
behind the
[Applause]
dumpster